do we do the intro thing or issues we
just start talking we do it just like if
you were tip I'd be so in trouble right
now I'd be so in trouble I'd be so in
trouble joy oh I've been watching during
quarantine I try to watch a bunch of
stuff like there's a lot of good things
that come out but I just keep going back
to the office you don't get tired
there's so much [ __ ] that I have to
catch up on
yeah what's the one you're looking
forward to the most - coming out or
something that's already there anything
whatever you guys finishing The Walking
Dead
really Oh finish it no I'm who's one of
those shows when it's been bad on season
six already whenever I think about
something new I just want to go back to
watching something I already know I like
like Game of Thrones over again no
because I broke my heart right back to
the future I watched all three of those
so gosh it's so good I think I've
watched all three really they have seen
like all the Indian ideology that the
best way to watch back to the future is
to just go back to practice I'm so
excited to watch I think I'm in
Washington part 3 tonight yeah I love
that one cuz I like cowboys and Indians
kind of movies I hated that one I mean
when I was like who's the best yeah one
in 2008 because it's almost goofy or
whenever no I just don't like the old
western feel it was a whole different
tone than the other move I think I liked
it because it's so drastically then we
watched it last night cuz we were like
we watched one and two back-to-back and
then we're like we've kind of put off
three we're like let's watch three
because we already watched the other two
and then we watched it and we really
liked it okay I mean the story is good
as a kid I just really the world it's
the world they kid because it was so
drastically different you're like that's
not my back to the future yeah and I
think cuz like it was so so far back in
history like I don't like period pieces
yeah so I'm like fish out of water is
fun when it was like 50s is like yeah
it's like fun and like they're all wowed
by the eighties [ __ ] he has or whatever
but then going all the way back to the
1800s I'm like that's too far I can see
why kids would really like part to that
ones I would say is the most most sci-fi
I'm just so goofy the kind of super
stimulating to you
I started watching a community good I
know it's on Netflix yeah that's why I'm
just like so it's created by the same
credit as Rick and Morty denna I tried
watching it back late I think once again
I was way too dumb and I'd understood
unity was pretty good it was got me
hooked to me you because it was like the
first of its kind word stick commie but
then it was like it was it was there was
moments of heartfelt in this so it was a
single cam right so that was new [ __ ]
back then before was all like sitcoms
iconic yeah yeah yeah yeah that's funny
because in there kind of the office
where I still push the boundaries with
like race jokes and like things like
that oh yeah I really call it out like
like oh that was [ __ ] racist you know
you can't see that well there it's meant
to highlight whoever's making that joke
as being a dumbass yeah like that's not
glorified in the show yeah yeah so it's
good like it got me hooked almost
immediately but I just kept watching
that oh my god check that out I'm super
into Bob's Burgers
I lost Bob oh yeah it's pretty good it's
no good I couldn't get that one really
no humor it's okay they love creating
the most awkward situations possible via
animation which is kind of weird I think
some something I find interesting about
it is that even though each character is
still weird and quirky they all of them
are also playing the straight man
character because how do you react to
the other weird guy yeah like yeah yeah
that makes sense
they're all so relatable yeah my shits
like South Park hands-down though for
cartoon stuff and do like South Park
there are different flavors I like Rick
and Morty alive yeah maybe we keep
talking about Bojack Bojack horseman
watching one or two of them I was like
it's alright it takes I heard it takes a
bit to get to but it's [ __ ] deep and
like real not like all these other shows
when I go awards right oh so many cuz
it's like there's things I like in real
life that happened that happened in this
show like if you [ __ ] over someone in a
TV show they resolve at the end of the
day right over that into the episode and
this one it carries on through seasons
simple [ __ ] like that and it's I like
the other show they made that got
canceled after Athena - cannibal God and
birdie yeah I like that one a lot -
Kemper the one with Ali
like they didn't promote it at all
though yeah I never even heard of it
yeah that's probably me it was both with
Tiffany Haddish and alley wall the big
ass the birds one yeah and I feel like
they didn't really promote it it's so
hard for me to get into cartoon stuff
watch walks rigor mortis yeah why tricky
boy I really try it is just hard for me
to watch pickle Rick why go to a pickle
Rick well open your brain man you gotta
get you got to build up to that because
you gotta know that you understand the
world yeah you have to watch it without
Tiger distracting you and you gotta
understand the relationship between pick
already yeah Rick and his daughter oh
yeah and how self-aware he's being
because if you don't understand him then
you can't understand the speech that
he's giving that's why pickle Rick is
good you have to evolve to that episode
also like in terms aren't pickle Rick if
you like story structure like writing
the den Harmon and how he writes and
like his story circle and how he relates
everything is like one of the best and
one of the most taut and push now
because this is even like Pixar movies
and hard for me to get into too I know
like I once I'm like halfway and I'm
super invested but like when it's actual
people I can get hooked within like
racket rounded or two so the first one
still takes me a minute just cuz I think
the world is so like non real it has to
convince you that this is really a
minute for like my Asperger brain to
like actually go okay these are actual
like people with thoughts and stuff I'm
the complete opposite I'm like the more
unreal it is the more I appreciate it
because it's just pure imagination at
this point and you're not relying on a
human's feelings and you have no [ __ ]
barriers and it's just all story so if
the story isn't good this isn't gonna be
good
mm whereas other shows because like it
is humans and it's kind of real and I
could relate I'm invested and the story
doesn't always have to be great I'm just
in it and I'm like like ozarks right now
it kind of sucked the third season car
but I'm invested and I'm and I want to
see these guys just like they're like
family now so like I got to see my best
yeah same with I'm like half invested
yeah but if it was a cartoon or anything
I'd give it up I'll be like oh those are
third season just felt like you're
edging yourself the whole time yeah
[ __ ] was that dude how weighted [ __ ]
two years for that [ __ ] I know
there's nothing Caporal me we're only in
the middle of it so no spoilers okay I
was gonna say we had spin I will say the
first two seasons I couldn't stop
watching it yeah third one it's it's
been tough they like get through being
with handmaids
Tate had maidens tail or whatever
[ __ ] house of cards man the last
season was horrible you know what
ammonia is the second season Briella
Academy where the [ __ ] where did that go
cuz I don't like the main actress oh
she's always so sad I'm okay just
walking slow and like but they don't
like focus on one character all the time
it's just like I like how it rotates and
I like them as an ensemble cast I like
to Hayden I don't know a necessary one
they ate in something Gallagher the
young kid that can like that yeah yeah
yeah the smart one the old man yeah
number five yeah yeah four smart old man
four or five old man that's young have
you guys been watching last dance
I know snow has it I'm not the only one
watching their sense I feel like I got
the gist of last dance though because
I've been following up on all the ESPN
interviews with all the basketball and
you guys also talk about it all the time
one thing that's cool is like you know
how we're waiting for Game of Thrones
it'd be one Episode a week yeah so as
soon as you're done you're like oh want
more I think they learned from that and
they dropped two episodes a week
oh [ __ ] really you get to watch one and
to watch another one you like and then
you feel kind of like satisfied is it
complete I think there's one more night
this week is it on Netflix ESPN so how
am I supposed to watch it then I'll
battles on networks
you gotta get ESPN's oh I'm not gonna do
that you lost you in for a year - I
don't even watch E as being more than
watch like Poker UFC yes too much
football with us is if we have a
football season I'm gonna learn a little
bit more football so I could appreciate
it but there's a ton of other
documentaries that are really good about
sports in there too I like sports like
30 for 30 yeah 30 for 30 s are really
good there's a ton of those even if
you're not a sports person yeah I just
don't like watching things that are
hyped by people at that moment like I'll
watch on to interest me later why you're
not an early adopter
no it's just like if I'm interested in
it yeah well but I'm not that big fan of
sports and I obviously know like the way
everyone's talking about it's gonna be
like super motivational all day
every episode like showing how crazy
this well it's like they're like people
talk about the Dennis Rodman wonder how
you guys were talking about how like he
like in terms of motivation or how
dedicated he was was like even creator
than that Kofi's it's not really
motivational though it's just more it's
more drama and the the inner workings
between the teammates rather than like
let me inspire you in the document I
just want to know how he [ __ ] a Carmen
Electra and you know weddings breasts oh
yeah and if he hung up I want to see him
hanging out with kim jongguk good oh
yeah
like it's crazy [ __ ] I think there's a
separate Dennis Rodman documentary on
ESPN 2
I actually really like watching Dennis
Rodman's a highlight reel on YouTube you
have Nick fans create highlight reels
are like different sport
yeah people his highlight reel is
[ __ ] insane it doesn't have a whole
lot of light
dunks or like him scoring or anything
like that but it's just him like
throwing his body around the court
looking down a die on the court he's so
tenacious under grab the rebound it's
crazy
he just goes in like he's doing extreme
sports on basketball huh yeah he like
dives headfirst I'm like there's so many
moments where he's like diving for a
ball I'm like it's like his whole body's
like flat like parallel to the ground
and you're like what is that gonna look
like once you land and he never pretty
and it doesn't I don't think he even
cares about that he's just going for the
ball yeah that's crazy
you guys like watch things as they're
popular cuz I'm always late to the game
I'm always late tire King you like with
all of you have Game of Thrones
we had a binges like after it even and
for what we do I feel like we should be
like with the current events so he could
be a part of the conversation I would be
on top of like the Netflix ones like
tiger king and like was that one with
the kid 11 stranger things
yeah strangers they're easy to binge
yeah because there's only like what a
few episodes three episodes or whatever
I'm like alright and they're pretty good
and the storylines there and you're like
you get invested people just mess it up
for me cuz then I'm like the same way
what documentaries are show sometimes
it's really good especially
documentaries but when people and put
the ovaries overhype it to where it's
never that good like people are going
crazy for a bird box and they're like 10
out of 10
what the [ __ ] was that so bad was it bad
I didn't think it was bad wanting to
watch it but I haven't seen it I don't
think was bad but if people were just
like this is like the craziest movie
that I've seen in a while I'm like okay
I think they don't watch a lot of movies
that was yeah I thought it was bad it
was just the first one out the gate cuz
that happened in January of last year
and so I was like after the holiday
seasons people are coming back to normal
schedules and that was just like the
first thing that like hit with people I
think it wasn't even that it was all
that Sandra Bullock mm-hmm you know what
I'm pretty excited about I've been
seeing like little sneak peeks of tom
hardy being Al Capone yeah oh [ __ ]
that's available now you can buy it you
can't that's a big no-no theaters no
theaters they get some today's I know I
think I dropped on the 18th what's today
a Taser 16 you're right so soon yeah I'm
like Dan I know what kind of actor he is
crazy dedicated I like all the roles he
even like some of them the story lines
aren't activities in it and he like
really brings that's why I heard the
cousin brings the noise yeah so I'm like
I'm really excited for that one you know
a little Chino might be I mean I'll
Pacino but the [ __ ] Michael B Jordan
might be Scarface yeah our face reboot
yeah remake the Coen brothers are
writing it
who else one brothers are writing it I
think the original director is still
directing and then my puppy dog just
have the coins directed I don't know why
they'd know did I wonder if he's a black
Cuban guy now
it sounds like it like he likes to move
his hips what are you gonna say hello to
my little friend
okay I hope it's a different storyline I
just I just don't like it when they just
keep doing remakes they when the when
the first ones already get let me take a
movie that was bad and they tried to
even better I feel like that makes sense
or add to another story like Blade
Runner
Oh true yeah yeah you know what I hate
passing the torch yeah is that the world
is so connected to the point where
people and different regions don't look
that different yeah like back then it's
like Miami like had a look and like you
know yeah but now it's like it's just
all kind of mush together yeah they kind
of look like la people too you know
do you think bigger butts you think that
like social media kind of did that
because people all try to copy each
other online and now everyone kind of
looks the same it is yeah I could just
tell like a British person just by
looking at them though I mean you got
[ __ ] up teeth no it's just like I look
extra dapper there's a certain whose way
people stand and body language that um
like they were I saw this study like
Americans stand more with their hip to
one side cuz we tired yeah and then we
sit too much
I mean English people stand straight up
or like European Europeans in general
yeah Europeans in general yeah and then
Asian people stand like with their belly
and squat yeah miss quad
[Music]
[Music]